[تصفيق]
أوه نعم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] من
الواضح أنه عاطفي جدًا هناك بعد
المباراة شارك أندريس عناقًا عاطفيًا مع
ابنه نيكو الذي كان أيضًا في كتر أه
يبث المباراة
أم كان الفوز حلمًا تحقق
للأب  ومن أجل الابن
وها هو Telemundo ،
انضم إلينا أندريس كانتور ، رئيس فريق Deportes المعلق على كأس العالم ،
الآن من DOA ، نحن سعداء جدًا من أجلك
أنت وابنك ويجب أن أقول إنني
أجش ومن أنفاسي لمجرد
الاستماع إليك  لقد انتظر إلى الأبد ،
شكرًا لك ، لقد انتظرت بصفتي أرجنتينيًا آه 36
عامًا ونصف حتى هذه اللحظة ،
حاولت أن أكون مؤلفًا قدر الإمكان ،
ومن الواضح أنني فقدتها هناك لبعض الوقت ،
لكنها كانت نهائيًا ملحميًا أعني
بكرة  كانت المشاعر مليئة بالمشاعر
ولم أشاهد نهائيًا أكثر هيمنة
في تاريخ كأس العالم لمدة 76 دقيقة ،
ثم حصلت الأرجنتين على
الدقيقتين المحددتين اللتين تعادلت فيهما فرنسا في المباراة ،
ثم
كان الوقت الإضافي أكثر من اللازم.